we're on problem number five
see the pie graph here survey results
survey results
and let's see
looks like well that looks like almost a
straight line
dividing it in half there and then
there's
this gets divided in half again looks
like that roughly
just like that
and
then
this is slightly bigger like that all
right
and this tells us
x is less than 20 for
30 percent of the time i don't even know
these represent x is greater than or
equal to 60 25 percent of the time
x is between 40
and less than 60
this is 25 percent of the time so it
could equal 40 but it's less than 60
and then it's between
it's greater than or equal to 20
and less than 40
20 percent of the time as survey results
the chart above shows the results when a
thousand people were asked how old are
you
the age they gave is represented by x
how many people said their age was less
than 40.
so x is less than 40.
well this category right here is x is
between 20 and 40. so it's it's this one
it's this one
plus all the people who said that they
were under the younger than 20 because
if you're less than 20 you're definitely
less than forty as well so it's both of
these combined
and this is thirty percent this is
twenty percent so if you combine is
thirty percent
plus twenty percent
equals fifty percent of the entire
population asked and a thousand people
were asked so fifty percent
times one thousand that's
straightforward that equals five hundred
people and that's choice d
next
problem problem six
which of the following could be the
remainders when four consecutive
positive integers are each divided by
three
are each divided by three interesting
so let's say you know we have x
x plus one x plus two x plus three right
these are four consecutive
positive integers
so
let's
i guess one way to think about it is
let's let's assume that this first one
is divisible by three right let's say
that x divided by three there's no
remainder so the remainder is zero
so when this number is divisible by
this number
three will you know x is divisible by
three so now when you divide x plus one
by three you're gonna have one left over
similarly you're gonna have two left
over
here
you're not gonna have three left over
right because if x is divisible by 3
then x plus 3 is also divisible by 3
right you're going to have a cycle it's
going to go back to a remainder of 0. so
this is a possible situation and
similarly if x had a remainder of 1 then
x plus 1 would have a remainder of 2
then x plus 2 would have a remainder of
and then this would have a remainder of
1 again so i don't know let's look at
the choices are any of these out there
well sure this is choice d actually the
first thing we did choice d was
0 1 2 0 which is d
and the key here is realizing that
you can't
you can't have
a remainder of
3 or four when you're dividing by three
right your remainder can only be zero
one or two so if you just with that
realization alone you can cancel out all
the choices that have a three or a four
in it you can't have a remainder of
three or four if you're dividing by
three and you can try that out right
because if you have a remainder by three
that means you can add you can divide
one more three into the number and have
a remainder of zero so you could cancel
out a b
c
and
e you can actually cancel out everything
so you just have to add that one
realization and use you'd have said the
choice is d because you can't have a
remainder of three or four if you're
dividing by three
next problem
problem seven
if y is inversely proportional to x so
that means that y is proportional to the
inverse of x so it's equal to some
constant times one over x that's what
inversely proportional means if we said
proportion would be y equals k times x
but it's inversely proportional
and these tell us that y is 15
when k
y is 15 when x is 5. so y is 15 is equal
to k times 1 over 5 right
y is 15 when x is equal to 5.
let's see let's multiply both sides of
this by 5.
so you get 5 times 15 is
is equal to k
right
so y is equal to 75 over x i just
rewrote this
what is the value of y when x is 25
so y is equal to 75
x is now 25
what's 75 divided by 25 well it's 3 and
that's choice c
problem 8.
if 2x
2x plus z is equal to 2y
and 2x
and then they also tell us that 2x
plus 2y
plus z is equal to 20.
what is the value of y
y is equal to what
so there's something interesting here we
can rewrite
this
second equation as
subtract 2y from both sides of this
equation right here and you get 2x
plus z is equal to 20
minus y
right
so this interesting you have a 2x plus z
here you have a 2x plus z here
let's make a new variable just a simple
you don't have to do this step but i
think this this will simplify things
let's call i don't know let's call the
variable
q
let's say q is equal to 2x plus z
right that's what they're trying to
confuse you they're giving you two
equations with three unknowns and you're
like how can i solve for one of them
well what's interesting is they have
you're solving for one of them and then
the relationship has a 2x plus z in both
equations so if you say q is equal to 2x
plus z everything starts to make sense
because then this top equation will
become
q
is equal to 2y and what will this bottom
equation be that would be q
is equal to 20
minus y right now you could set these
equal to each other
y is equal to 20 minus y
add y to both sides you get 3y is equal
to
20.
am i doing that right 3y is equal to
20. is that you add y to both sides y is
equal to 20 over 3.
they don't have that choice so i must
have made a mistake let me see if i can
let me redo the problem must have made a
mistake problem 8.
so they're telling us 2x
plus z is equal to 2y
and then they tell us 2x
plus 2y
plus z
is equal to 20.
what is the value of y okay the second
equation can be written as 2x plus z is
equal to 20
minus 2y
and this top equation is still 2x plus z
is equal to 2y oh i see i i had dropped
a y someplace
so
this must equal this because they both
equal 2x plus c i don't even have to do
all that substitution with q i think you
see
that 2x z equals this 2x plus c equals
this so this must equal this so 2y is
equal to 20
minus 2y
add 2i to both sides you get 4y is equal
to 20
y is equal to 5 and that is choice a
i'll see in the next video
oh whoops i didn't delete
sorry